you can just follow your list or check
out the what's new or what's hot tabs or
you can dig a little deeper into the
Netflix archives to find some truly
outstanding under-the-radar films here's
a look at some of the best stuff to add
to your queue then next time you don't
know what to watch the south korean film
industry is thriving and revenger is one
of the most bone-shattering creative
exports direct advice jung-hwan lee
revenger focuses on protagonist kim yeol
who's sentenced to life in prison on an
island known only as a p101
the island is a dumping ground to keep
the most violent criminals away from
society and supposedly impossible to
escape from but here's the twist
Yul isn't trying to get out he got
himself thrown into a p101 on purpose to
find the man responsible for the brutal
murders of his family and avenge their
deaths it quickly connects with other
inmates who were wrongfully sentenced
and puts his investigative skills and
his combat expertise to good use to
complete his mission the plot of revenge
ER is certainly predictable enough to
anyone who enjoys action films but the
fight scenes are packed with the kind of
choreography that will make you ask wait
how did he do that it's hard to take
your eyes off the insanely talented star
Bruce Khan as he takes down the bad guys
one by one based on a true story solo
was originally released in Spain in
August 2018 and now Netflix is bringing
it to international audiences when
Alvaro wakes up hungover and depressed
in his Jeep in the Canary Islands all he
can think about is the fight he just had
with his girlfriend and his newfound
discovery that his close friend nello is
leaving him behind to move to Canada he
decides to grab his surfboard and catch
a few waves to get his mind off
everything but on his way down to the
beach he falls and slides down the
cliffs into the water crashing against
the rocks below he hits his head and
begins hallucinating reflecting on his
life and his relationships as he
struggles to keep breathing in solo the
gorgeous setting of the Canary Islands
suddenly becomes foreboding and
dangerous solo is the kind of film that
prompts you to consider what would run
through your mind if you are fighting
for survival it's not an easy watch but
one that will stay with you not only is
Lionheart the first Nigerian Netflix
original it's also Nigerian superstar
Genevieve Nagi's directorial debut and
she just so happens to be
star of the film as well putting her
talents on full display when her father
has to step back from running his
transport company because of medical
issues his daughter a day as a decides
she's ready to take on the challenge and
appoints her uncle God's will who proves
tough to work with when a day's a and
God's will discover that the company's
finances are in shambles
so given our current situation can you
tell us how bad the numbers are but try
abysmal matter they're forced to set
their differences aside and cooperate in
order to save the business
this lighthearted family drama serves up
more than just a few laughs and a strong
feminist message kingdom is another
solid Netflix original out of South
Korea adapted from the webcomic series
Kingdom of the Gods this genre bending
series pulls its inspiration from both
historical fiction and creepy zombie
flicks to create a fresh and exciting
storyline when a dead King comes back to
life his resurrection seems to be the
catalyst for a plague of mysterious
origins in order to save the kingdom the
crown prince must accept that the fight
for their survival is now his burden to
bear royal politics and supernatural
threats both vie for the center stage in
this visually stunning series with only
six episodes kingdom is easy to watch in
a single weekend which is ideal because
once you hit play you won't want to get
up until you watch the season finale and
here's the good news
season 2 started production in early
2019 close is based on the life of
famous bodyguard Jackie Davis who once
worked for none other than Harry Potter
author JK Rowling directed by Vikki
Juicin the film stars Noomi Rapace as
Sam a highly skilled bodyguard who can
make it out of any dangerous situation
unscathed
Sam ends up being assigned to protect
spoiled and naive teenage heiress Zoe
Tanner who is set to inherit the wealth
from her father's mining company take
him to the kitchen he needs to be fed
we leave in an hour you might want to
change the to head to Morocco where Zoey
will supposedly be staying at a
high-security compound to ensure her
safety they quickly find themselves
under attack
Sam decides that being a protector isn't
enough it's her responsibility to teach
Zoey how to fight back and figure out
exactly who's coming after her repose
steals the show in this film
she's a tough protagonist with the
tender side while this high-stakes drama
has been criticized for a messy third
act it's entertaining enough to invest
in 90 minutes of your time directed by
Steven Soderbergh the sports drama high
flying bird is unique in both plot and
production for starters it was shot
entirely on an iPhone during a pro
basketball lockout rookie player Eric
Scott wonders if his career has already
hit a dead end until raid Burke suggests
an unorthodox business model that could
revive the sport and disrupt the entire
industry instead of relying on the
wealthy team owners to cave and end the
stalemate why not let the players
themselves take the reins and run their
own league leveraging the Internet to
independently broadcast games to
millions what you saw yesterday was just
a glimmer a lightning flash of what
could be the beginning of a whole new
industry the economic critique at the
core of the film takes high flying bird
outside the realm of traditional sports
movies the biting commentary on the
racial and class dynamics within the
world of professional sports are
apparent in real life yet these issues
are often ignored by casual fans it's
easy to see pro athletes as privileged
but high-flying bird questions the power
structure integral to this industry when
the owners reap profits off the athletes
who put in years of hard work who really
comes out on top
equal parts buddy comedy and moving
tearjerker paddle 10 beginning illness
but it's not an inspirational film about
beating a disease and going on to live a
happy life when Michael finds out that
he has stomach cancer which is doctor
deems incurable he has no interest in
proving her wrong instead he decides he
wants to die on his own terms with a
company of his neighbor and only real
friend Andy mark doesn't have any major
bucket list items to check off there is
no dramatic leap out of a plane no
declarations of love to a long-lost X
instead mark wants pizza nights complete
with
horny kung-fu films and then reenact
those corny kung fu films at an open mic
night and a great battle ensues and and
and Lu winds up for what will become
known as the death punch he also wants
to hang out with Andy and play a few
more rounds of paddle ttan a racquetball
game the pair invented a film-like
paddle 10 risks falling into feel-good
cliches familiar to this general
narrative but the refreshingly authentic
friendship between these two misfits
makes the movie something that goes far
beyond the usual story mark doesn't
harbor any illusions about a miraculous
recovery or a triumph over the
impossible to journey through the quiet
acceptance of his own fate he only meets
the companionship of a true friend it's
a reminder that meaning isn't always
found in grand sweeping moments but in
the connections with those we love
you're probably already familiar with
Chua tell Ejiofor from his work as an
actor an impressive filmography that
includes prestigious dramas like
children of men and blockbusters like
dr. strange not only does the boy who
harnessed the wind mark his feature
directorial debut he also wrote the
script and appears as the father of the
young protagonist the film is based on
the real life of William Kirk Lamba and
the memoir that detailed his incredible
achievements as a young boy growing up
in a small village in Malawi curious and
inventive William is barred from
attending school when his parents can no
longer pay the fees his science teacher
however continues teaching him and
allowing him to use the library when his
village suffers from a long drought that
results in famine William must put his
skills to good use to create a windmill
that will power an electric water pump
there are no surprising twists or turns
it's a straightforward story that leads
to a conclusion you'll probably see
coming but Williams real-life grit and
ingenuity are truly inspiring if you're
looking for another unsettling sci-fi
series with the same feel as Black
Mirror osmosis will be right up your
alley
this French series explores a future in
which people can use an innovative new
dating app to find their soul mate but
it's not as simple as swiping right
instead the service mines data from the
users brain on the surface it actually
seems pretty innocent at first after all
if you could find the one with perfect
accuracy without having to navigate the
complicated landscape of modern dating
you
probably be tempted to give it a shot
but naturally there are some unintended
consequences as the developers behind
the service warned the participants
every experiment has a margin of error
while the idea behind the series isn't
exactly groundbreaking the story itself
is engaging and suspenseful and the
Futurist virtual reality sequences make
for some unique cinematography when it
comes to sheer intensity black summer is
a step up from classic zombie films in
this series the undead aren't lumbering
around aimlessly they're fast they're
hungry and they're downright terrifying
in the days following the onset of a
zombie apocalypse a group of desperate
strangers bands together hoping that
strength and numbers will increase their
chances of survival sure that sounds
like the beginning of any story about
the collapse of society but black summer
is relentless in showcasing the full
extent of the ensuing violence the
characters don't get a moment to breathe
and neither does the viewer be prepared
for nauseating gore and plenty of jump
scares even if you only skimmed Lord of
the Flies in high school you probably
remember the basic plot a group of boys
gets stranded on an island and attempt
to organize their own mini society until
help arrives but it devolves into chaos
and tragedy ensues that's also the
general storyline in the series the
society but this modern take on the
dilemma from the classic novel doesn't
feel like a mere rehash with electricity
and iPhones when students return from a
school trip to find that everyone in
their town has vanished and the
community is now surrounded by an
impenetrable forest they quickly realize
that their ill equipped to handle what
comes next
nonsense is Hebrew it means you've been
weighed in the balance and found wanting
although teenagers are the audience most
likely to find the characters relatable
you don't have to be a high school
student to appreciate the ensemble cast
and realistic take on adolescent
conflict against an apocalyptic backdrop
from the first episode viewers are sure
to find themselves gripped by the
mystery is the town at the center of
some grand experiment or have they
slipped into a parallel universe is help
on the way and if it arrives will it be
too late check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]